how much of directing at the highest
levels in this business is about skills
you have at your craft versus people
skills and politics so I had I had a I
had a meeting for a show or for a
network rather last week and we got into
a conversation about soft skills right
um which are what we were kind of
talking about earlier like you can have
the best shot list in the world but the
soft skills help you get somebody out
the trailer help you convince somebody
that the work they're doing is great
help you you know
deal with uh
whatever scenario that might arise right
um I think that
a director without humanity is going to
be is going to have challenges doing
their job because you know I think back
to
being younger and you're just so focused
on
gotta get the shot like
why if everybody would just come here
and do what I'm ready to do we could get
you know I mean like like you're just
it's all about getting this thing done
you're feeling the burdens and the
pressure of the money you know because
you're probably over over leveraged and
you're tired and why won't they just do
what I want them to do and you know
that
that is also natural when you don't have
the tools to you know deal with the
pressures of the job but I think
as you learn them you do recognize that
um
those soft skills are are key you know
and and look you know I've done I've
done
episodes as a as a guest director where
I've been brought to a show to direct an
episode and that is at that point they
think that you can do it they think
you're competent and you can keep you
won't mess up their show right
um then
there comes a point where like now I'm a
producing director on a show and a
co-executive producer now they're saying
well
we think you're someone that can help
work with all the directors will hire
can help you know be a liaison between
post and the producers for the creative
now that's a different person
in terms of skills right
um then there's the you know pilot
director you know like I have a pilot
I'm attached to that's a different thing
because they're looking for someone who
can do both of those things while also
you know maybe have more owner have a
have a little more ownership of it as a
director than a guest director because
you're creating a look for a show
um so you're marrying like so many
different parts of of your of what you
do
um and knowing when and when and why to
apply pressure I think is the is the
um directors you know challenge
can you tell us about how to politic and
what is that
I think you know
how to politic I think is is that same
kind of answer like knowing when to
apply pressure some things when I was
when I was when I was working as faculty
um I used to be in a lot of meetings
um a lot of meetings and I would just
kind of
I had a joke where I was like
people can talk about whatever they want
until it sounds like there's about to be
a policy change
that's going to affect the job I do I
can sit here and be
unmoved because some I don't know why
that person may be performing what
they're doing right now maybe they're
making a stance for some reason I have
no idea about and this person has
tension with them and that person always
says something and this person doesn't
want to you know reveal what they don't
what you know all these things but the
moment it sounds like there's about to
be a new pile of work on my desk well
now uh I have a thought you know and so
you I just kind of learned like
when is
be like read the room
and see what's really happening and
whether or not something impactful is
happening something performative is
happening you know
and whether or not what you might
be getting ready to say matters or is
going to have an impact
um
and I mean I I think that was a that was
one of the best things that again I
didn't know I was learning but I think
that was one of the best things I
learned being in like a university
environment and so
I try and you know
maintain vigilance in
reading a room and seeing what's
happening and whether or not you know
and and and
measuring my response
um to get what I'm looking to get and
that's not you know I'll flip this and
say that's not to say that everything is
a manipulation and everything but you
know
I can I can remember one time being
called into a trailer
hair makeup trailer
um with like you know show Runners star
actor actress and like hair makeup and
I'm being asked all these questions and
I'm like
what's happening and it was about a
scene that we had agreed to shoot a
certain way and then I'm listening and
listening and listening and I'm like oh
what I'm recognizing here because I'm
not being I'm not like
uh like being super responsive to like
the fact like first off we've already
talked about this you know I mean like
I'm sorry I can't talk talk because I
know the more you talk the more I'm
going to get something that I can begin
to understand and
you know I don't know if it was three
minutes or or ten it felt like 30 but I
was like oh it sounds like to me and my
guess here that this actress wants the
body double but doesn't want to ask for
it
and
I'm pretty sure that's what it was and I
said you know well why don't we just do
the body devil blah blah because there
were all these things connected it
seemed to her for that request you know
what I mean and like
um
we I I noticed that our relationship
kind of got that much better after that
and I was just reading the room and
trying to like I could say we've talked
about it three times but like does that
matter
you know so I think it's it's be it's
allowing people to be people
you know what I mean and and trying to
um
be aware of like the multiple ways you
can get
to an end result that
maintains the Integrity of what you set
out to do
so there's not just subtexts on the page
there's there's some on set too oh yeah
yeah what if we think we have soft
skills but we really don't how does how
does the
production show is that how do other
people show us that we actually don't
have the soft skills we thought we had
well that that makes me reach for the
book oh good okay because in in the book
in the in the introduction
um you know because
as with anything I'm
you write something and and for me I
want to go like well what
will make you listen to this right and
so in the introduction
um
yeah here we go
um there are three questions that uh
I'll just I'll actually read you because
it's not a it's not a long thing uh in
2014 after six unsuccessful years of
unrealized efforts to break into
episodic television directing I asked
myself a series of probing existential
questions
and I think these three questions
answered the question about like what if
you think you've got soft skills or but
you know things aren't happening I asked
what's not working
what if everything I'm doing is wrong
and how can I pivot
so if you think that you've got those
skills but you ask yourself what's not
working and you look and you see what my
films do well
but like
this isn't happening maybe it's that
maybe I don't know the industry and the
mechanics of the business well enough
you know maybe I keep making films that
if I had read the trades I could have
seen that there were already two films
in development about that thing and mine
was never going to compete you know I
think that kind of those kind of
questions that
demand self-reflection
um help you
avoid getting mired into something that
you think is what it's not
can we learn soft skills can we learn
how to I mean we all think we know how
to work with other people but sometimes
life shows us that that's not the case I
think we can learn them I had to learn
them
yeah like I mean I think I had some
a handful of them you know but to your
earlier question like like if I would
have
been offered TV coming out of out of
Sundance
and it would have been different
you know and so I think and I and over
the next you know years years and even
you know I learned a new soft skill last
week I'm sure you know
um I think that I think the thing it's
not the it's not the ability to learn
it's the appetite to learn
right because we can we can keep
learning until the day we die you know
but if we think that we've we've got it
all figured out then
that's off the table